hey you have to see this uh the Texas
Attorney General Ken Paxton says he is
willing and able to defend a law that
bans gay sex in private now these are
sometimes referred to as sodomy laws and
obviously if you are a small government
conservative the first thing you would
do is start trying to pass laws about
what people can do in the privacy of
their own bedroom no that's not at all
what you would do but it is a tired
example of how the values they state are
not the actual values they espouse when
it is no longer convenient to them it is
absurd and terrifying that Ken Paxton is
saying hey let's look at ways to roll
back LGBT rights I mean the fact that
that's happening even in some general
sense is horrifying we may be naively
hoped in 2015 after the gay marriage
decision that we were all moving beyond
these issues of trying to limit the
rights of LGBT people that we have seen
from the right we very quickly realized
they're not giving up they're just going
to shift the battle lines they shifted
from gay marriage to for example
religious freedom
to discriminate against gay people
uh bathroom stuff trans you all know the
stuff so now we hear from Ken Paxton I
have a clip here uh he is of course
always couching this as States should
get to decide
what types of sex people can have
in their bedroom but we're not falling
for it take a look at this uh would you
as attorney general be comfortable
defending a law that once again outlawed
sodomy the question Lawrence again or
Griswold uh or gay marriage uh that came
from the state legislature to to put to
the test what Justice Thomas said
yeah I mean there's all kinds of issues
here but certainly the Supreme Court has
stepped into issues that I don't think
there was any constitutional provision
dealing with they were legislative
issues wow and this is one of those
issues and there may be more so
understand the gist of what he is saying
because these guys are pretty damn good
at using euphemism and talking around
issues what Ken Paxton fundamentally is
saying is that the Supreme Court has
overstepped the same way that they say
well the Supreme Court overstepped on
gay marriage the Supreme Court
overstepped on Roe v Wade which they've
since been able to get rolled back and
they say States should get to decide
these things but at the end of the day
this is very much like those who say the
Civil War was not about slavery it was
about states rights ah but it was not
about states rights to determine we're
going to use the inch or the centimeter
right it was about states rights to
determine they want to continue making
it legal to own people and force them to
do work for you as slaves and very much
the same way what Ken Paxton is saying
here is I can very much defend the laws
in which Texas might ban gay sex in the
privacy of bedrooms and make it a crime
which is insanely overreaching for
government especially for people
claiming that they are small government
conservatives he's not going to say it
that way he said we believe it can be
defended because the Supreme Court has
overreached in certain ways Beyond Where
We Believe
it's a very clear indication that Paxton
and other so-called conservatives are
not only comfortable but are actively
working and interested in rolling back
lgtb LGBT rights we said that this would
happen uh right after the Roe v Wade
decision it is a disgusting violation of
Human Rights it's a step towards more
discrimination towards more oppression
and it goes against their own stated
principles and the fact that Paxton is
willing to publicly come out and say
discriminatory disgusting oppressive law
well we're going to defend states rights
because that's my job under the
Constitution it shows either or both he
doesn't actually understand what it
means to have rights or
he assumes the people who support him
don't
and that's much the way that Fox News
operates like I don't literally think
Fox News hosts believe a lot of the crap
they say but they believe Their audience
will believe it and they're mostly
correct and that has been much of Ken
Paxton and in general the Texas governor
and Lieutenant Governor's Mo which is we
will assume our voters don't know the
difference and this stuff will sound
pretty damn good to them so
extraordinarily dangerous whether Paxton
is actually going to fight to again ban
certain types of sex in people's private
homes between consenting adults I don't
know I'm hoping it doesn't actually get
to that point but he's certainly saying
all the things that make us think that's
what's coming make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
what a week of programs we have for you
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the the bad habits that
consume far too many of us including
ones that harm our health fume is a
natural diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to trade
out your negative habit for a positive
one fume is not a vape it's a
non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fumuses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fumes new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap that's fun to
fidget with its fume's goal to make
switching easy or even enjoyable they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below